Alexandra Ocasio Cortez isn't just in a
feud with anyone who thinks America
should have a border she's also in a
spat with the founder of barstool sports
Dave Portnoy recently made a series of
anti-union tweets in the course of which
he said he'd fire anybody on his staff
who contacted a certain pro-union
journalist and in response a OSI accused
him of breaking the law she doesn't care
when 20 million illegal immigrants break
the law by breaking into the country but
when she can use it to shut down a
functioning business infractions of the
law are far more important Dave Portnoy
says he wants to have a debate with IOC
she's being strangely coy about that but
Dave is with us today she's a threatened
to rain down the might of the federal
government on you Dave are you cowering
I'm not cowering I'd love to talk to her
have her debate but I don't think she's
gonna do it she did use parcels sports
and my name in the club we have a big
following to try to raise some donations
she sends out a letter such that's
writing us but you know I I doubt she's
gonna step to the podium now I saw a
fascinating discussion by our friends on
Fox Business about an hour ago who
seemed to think you were screwed you're
going down you're finished yeah that
apparently some national labor review
board regulation Trump's this so-called
First Amendment thing with so-called
freedom of speech and Steve Forbes
former presidential candidate Steve
Forbes seems to think you should be
quaking in your shoes yeah I saw I saw
the debate I actually tweeted out I
called it a debate on the genius at they
importantly because some people seem to
be thinking I was playing game
assessment trolling the people think I'm
going to jail they're idiots let me
clarify real quick we are a comedy site
we're pretty pretty clear about that
we have no union a parcel sport nobody
is trying to make a union at parce
little sports I actually the whole Union
debate it's just a site that I don't
like not the ringer 2015 Gawker which is
a lowlife loser site yep they formed a
union of nitwits with no talent and I
was making fun of them I wasn't talking
about you know factories I actually
don't know what
that I'm talking about barstool sports
and I was making fun of our own
employees saying if you try to make a
union I'll crush you and then these
morons who have no idea what we do jump
into the fray like aoc crazy oh right I
want credit when that takes off by that
Alexandra Oh crazy Oh Cortez he said it
first first because I know Donald's
gonna use it I get the credit for that
because it's a really good one but they
don't know what they're talking about
yeah you jump into the mud and hey guess
what we had the biggest day we've ever
had in bar select you got dragged out of
the Super Bowl in handcuffs because
Roger Goodell doesn't like me right so
it's a big game and the people who are
tweeting us the blue checkmarks and all
these people they should spend less time
tweeting more time working and then they
won't have to worry about the union's so
aoc who can only raise fifteen hundred
and twenty five dollars from her own
constituents has actually with a single
tweet of hers raised far more money for
you yeah it's line in our pockets and
she's trying to the same now again I
don't think she has any clue who we are
or what we do she just jumped in the
fray like an idiot and now it helped us
but yeah it was a good day for barstool
it continues to be if I had a nickel for
every time people don't know what we do
say I'm going to jail I would be serving
like oh well I guess nickel but a
hundred life sentences no that's fair
he's say he's not a danger of taking
this to the Supreme Court folks hey
barstool sports should be sued for its
cricket coverage which is a little
wobbly maybe you have to go to the
tearoom Sports for that Dave poor boy
thank you very much good luck good luck
with Alexander crazy Oh Cortes that does
deserve to take off